a major medical journal published a
peer-reviewed research article last
month
on an urgent disease that scientists say
we need to stop
i'm not talking about the wu flu the
kung flu the lung past second not that
i am talking i kid you not about
whiteness which the author dr donald
moss describes as
parasitic and for which he hopes to find
a quote permanent cure
a major anti-trump narrative falls apart
kamala harris's propaganda falls flat in
guatemala
we do not have the cure to whiteness on
this show but we do have the cure to
fake news i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jorge felipe
gonzalez who says
oh the nightmares i would have had as a
kid with that weirdo
singing on a kids show talking about the
drag queens singing about how little
boys are little girls on nickelodeon
yes one could have nightmares i mean
that truly
you know very obviously that dude is
dressed up like a clown right he's a guy
he's just he's dressed up like a clown
in a way where he's pretending to be a
real thing unlike a clown which is just
pretending
to be some sort of silly fictional
character the thing that scares me about
it though is
is the children who wouldn't be scared
you know the children who will look at
this and say oh look it's colorful oh
the tune is catchy oh it's just another
sort of clown
and who will imbibe this kind of insane
ideology because that is the point
that's why they're going
after all of the kids shows sometimes
you got to tune that out when you want
to tune
in once you've tuned that out you got to
check out your ray-cons
a pair of raycon wireless earbuds in
your ears can make
all the difference no matter what you're
listening to maybe you're listening to
music that's cool maybe you're listening
to
a great new audiobook called speechless
controlling words controlling minds
maybe you're listening to your favorite
podcast
you will get crisp powerful beats at
half the price of the other premium
audio brands
i'm going to try to be diplomatic when i
say this raycons
it's just a superior product to the
other versions of this on the market
okay and at a much better price
and raycons look great and they feel
even better they come in a range of cool
colors
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable in-ear fit
raycons are built to go wherever you go
with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing
and a compact charging case i
cannot urge you strongly enough go get
ray guns right now some good audio is
really going to amplify your experience
get you out there and move in
right now raycon's offering 15 off all
their products from my listeners
what you got to do is go to buy
raycon.com knowles there you will get 15
off your entire rake on order such a
good deal you're going to want to buy a
pair and a spare
that is 15 off it buy raycon.com knowles
by raycon.com
knowles whiteness as a parasitic
disease for which we must find a
permanent cure a permanent what's a
what's another term for permanent cure
you might say a permanent cure would be
like a i don't know like a final
solution you know or some i don't
how do you cure whiteness how do you
cure it well
there's only one way to do that and it's
pretty ghastly
this is what this doctor donald moss
says in the article on having whiteness
parasitic whiteness renders its hosts
appetites
voracious insatiable and perverse these
deformed appetites particularly target
non-white peoples once established these
appetites are nearly impossible to
eliminate
effective treatment consists of a
combination of psychic and social
historical interventions
such interventions can reasonably aim
only to reshape
whiteness's infiltrated appetites to
reduce their intensity
redistribute their aims and occasionally
turn those aims toward the work of
reparations
when remembered and represented the
ravages
wreaked but reeked or wrought this guy
he's not the brightest bulb in the pack
the ravages reeked
by the chronic condition can function
either as
warning never again or as temptation
great again memorialization alone
therefore is no
guarantee against regression there is
not yet a permanent cure okay when i
first read this i assumed it was satire
i i assumed he was joking and showing
how crazy this anti-white ideology has
become
the anti-white ideology embodied now
most notably by critical race theory
but by all sorts of leftist ideologies
that developed over the last century but
i think he's serious
i think he's serious about this of
course it is
cliche and tedious and ridiculous to say
imagine if the situation were reversed
imagine if someone published an article
about how black people are evil and that
we need a permanent cure and how they
specifically target non they
specifically target white people and all
this sort of thing
that that would be you you would be run
out of town on a rail i mean you'd be
basically
booted from the country you'd probably
end up in a terror watch list or
something
but this sort of thing is presented in a
major medical journal peer review i mean
i don't i don't think peer review means
anything at all i think it's a complete
farce
but people seem to have some respect for
it well this is an article in a
respectable journal saying that that
white people are evil and
they tell us by the way on the left that
uh this is delusional you know there
are all these sorts of theories out
there
over the what this is all really about
is this ideological is this sexual is
this
uh racial what where where is the
politics really hinging right now
and this guy's answer is obviously
the racial answer he's saying he is
saying and and there have been plenty of
people who have claimed this and then
the left comes in and says you're all
kooks and conspiracy theorists
this guy is saying we hate you because
you're white and we want to get rid of
all the white people right that's what
he's saying
the the issue of racial consciousness
here is a really strange one
because whites uniquely
don't have a racial consciousness you
can see pew
research did a survey about this a few
years ago a survey
of different racial groups and asked
them
is your race very important or somewhat
important to your identity
and for every single racial group more
than 50
of people said yes it is except for
white people
so for every group it was greater than
50 for black people it was greater than
70
for white people that number was just 15
so whites do not have a racial
consciousness i don't think of things
generally in racial terms i think i
guess i'm a white person so there it is
am i a white person i don't know i'm a
little swarthy but
i suppose i would be classified that way
i don't think of things that way i think
of things
in philosophical terms religious terms
ideological terms maybe geographic terms
but race is pretty low on the list and
yet this guy
is coming out and he's he's not
attacking people
because they're conservative he's not
he's attacking trump supporters right he
says great again
but he's not attacking them specifically
because they're trump supporters he's
not attacking them
because they're christian he's not
attacking them because they're american
he is attacking them because they are
white
and the simple fact is that the more
this ideology progresses
you will see an intensification of
white racial consciousness there's just
no alternative to that
you cannot have a political regime in
which every single group is told
to think primarily if not exclusively
about their race
and in which only one racial group can
be castigated can
can have calls for genocide in a major
medical journal and
not have that racial consciousness
increase i don't think this is good for
politics i don't think
that a heightening of racial
consciousness
and i think inevitably racial tension is
good for for american politics but
in political battles your opponents get
a say and the opponents are very clear
here
the left by the way i think this
doctor's a white guy not positive i
think he is though
the name like donald moss he doesn't he
sounds like a guy from like oregon or
something you know
a guy who has like a thin beard and
wears lots of
like thin flannel that's just the image
in my mind
this guy is saying we are going to
fight political battles on racial
grounds and so we conservatives can say
okay well we don't want to do that
but the left gets a say too and the left
has made its decision
i'll i'll show you how how this sort of
thing works because
it's being discussed in racial terms
obviously there's an ideological aspect
so there's a blm terrorist who burned
down a police station
during the riots last year i suppose
there were probably many people who did
this
but one of them is this guy bryce
michael williams he's 27 years old
he pled guilty to setting fire to a
minneapolis police station
as part of the riots that sprung up over
george floyd
williams because of this was sentenced
to two years and three months in prison
for burning down a police station
he was also ordered to pay 12 million
dollars in restitution something tells
me that this fella is not going to be
making 12 million dollars anytime soon
but the u.s district judge patrick
schultz while he was sent
censor as censoring well he was
certainly not censoring this guy well he
was sentencing this guy
he referred to williams the gu the blm
terrorist who burned down a police
station
as quote a good person who made a
terrible mistake
he's a good person he's just you know
he's just so misunderstood and sometimes
you know you have a bad day you wake up
on the wrong side of the bed and you
burn your breakfast
and you go to work and your boss you
know is kind of rude to you
and you know sometimes you just burn
down a police station don't
who among us has not just occasionally
when life gets a little tough burned
down a police station he's basically a
good person
right he's actually recommending that
the sentence be reduced
but reduced i believe even below the
federal guidelines
meanwhile meanwhile trump supporters
who trespassed at the capitol
and who wore the horn hat and danced on
a desk
and who stole nancy pelosi's lectern
they are going to be sentenced to a
decade or more
in prison there will be no leniency
they're being called terrorists they're
being called insurrectionists
every single one of them anybody who
went near the capitol
on january 6th is having their lives
destroyed and they are going to have the
book thrown at them they're not
good people who made a terrible mistake
and by the way
trespassing at the capitol and wearing
the horn hat
is not the same as burning down a police
station it is much
much worse to burn down a police station
than to wear the silly costumes at the
capitol and jump up and down
and hoot and holler and mess up people's
desks it's worse
okay it's worse to burn down the police
station but
the trump supporters might rot in jail
the judge sums this up
the reason that i i wanted to quote what
the judge said here is
because that's not the conclusion he
reached you can't look at a guy burns
down a playstation say actually he's a
good guy
the good person line is the premise that
the judge is starting with
the premise in the society and there's
obviously a racial aspect to this
because
the riots that that this guy burned down
the police station during were racial
riots
part of black lives matter and the
premise is that black liberal activists
are good people
and white trump supporters are bad
people and that's just
it it's even in the psychology journal
right that
make great again right it's a conflation
of white people and trump supporters i
don't think that's fair
let's not forget donald trump increased
the number of
non-white voters who came actually the
only group that he lost votes during
from in 2020 was white people
but that's what they're conflating here
and they're beginning with this premise
black liberal
good white conservative bad
and so of course the judge was going to
say this about this guy it's just a fact
it had the fact
the actual facts of what he did are
completely
irrelevant because of those evil
terrible trump supporters
donald trump who colluded with russia
and who uh what else did he do
he sold our country out he had bad deals
in ukraine you remember that
what else did he do he oh do you
remember when he tear-gassed and
brutalized all those peaceful protesters
at lafayette square you remember then he
held the bible up do you remember that
well
actually that's just another one of
these anti-trump narratives this fake
news
that had been pushed for months and
months on end by the left
and by the squishy right that the the
court jester conservatives pushed by
that
new new report out says just not true
when you want to get the truth when you
want to get the truth on pricing when
you want to get the truth on
on every kind of part available for your
car or truck
where you gonna go you're gonna go to
rockauto.com there's no question about
it rockauto.com
will save you so much dignity
it'll save you time and money too but so
much dignity because
you go into the auto parts store right
and you you say okay i need i need
this part for my car truck and they'll
say well is it is your car this this
version or that version or the lx or the
px or the qx or whatever
then they ask you this they humiliate
you you don't have the answers they go
in the back of the shop
they don't have the parts they probably
don't have any parts back there they go
on
the internet they probably go to
rockauto.com they order the part they
charge you twice as much
don't don't degrade yourself in that way
head on over rockauto.com always has the
lowest prices possible
they don't change their prices every day
and tuesday morning it's this price but
then you got a wednesday it's that no
it's very simple
they got the same prices for pros that
they have for do-it-yourselfers it's a
family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years and the catalog is so simple to
navigate
even i can do it how about that head on
over to rockauto.com
right now check out every part available
for your car or truck and then write
knowles canon wles
in there how did you hear about xbox so
they know that we sent you president
trump
used violence against peaceful
protesters
to clear a public park to take a photo
op
next to saint john's church it was worse
than that elizabeth warren says
the president united states tear-gassed
peaceful protesters joe biden
he's using the american military against
the american people hillary clinton
tonight the president of the united
states used the american military
to shoot peaceful protesters with rubber
bullets and tear gas them cnn's oliver
darcy
peaceful protesters just had rubber
bullets and tear gas
shot at them so the president could have
a photo op john favreau who's a lefty
podcaster and he
i think he worked for obama the
president had peaceful protesters shot
with tear gas and rubber bullets we
could get his photo taken kamala says
donald trump just tear gas peaceful
protesters for a photo op and david
french
who is a i guess you should call him
what a neoconservative or something he's
a
former republican who now spends all of
his time attacking republicans and
conservatives he says quote
this from the washington post is an
extraordinary piece of journalism
it's a video timeline of the federal law
enforcement attack on peaceful
protesters at lafayette square
this is how the trump administration
violently cleared the path for photo op
just not true just not true lump that
one away with the easter bunny
and the tooth fairy it didn't happen
according to a watchdog report
being reported not by not by fox news
not by
the daily wire not by by cnn even cnn's
admitting this
watchdog report finds the park police
did not clear racial injustice
protesters from lafayette park
for trump's visit to saint john's church
last june
this comes a report from the interior
department's inspector generals this is
a government watchdog within the
government
it just didn't happen you can read the
article yourself that will be the one
time this year that you go to cnn.com
it was completely fake news and no one
will be held responsible for this none
of these people
one one of these people who lied about
this is currently the president the
other one
is the vice president uh the
the other one the third one hillary
clinton pretended to be the president
and questioned the results of a 2016
election we didn't hear calls about how
that was threatening our democracy back
then but now it's a big problem
and even squish former republicans you
know people who present themselves as
conservative but who really spend all of
their time
attacking conservatives and punching
right and attacking the republican party
all of them lied about this maybe they
didn't lie maybe they just were too
stupid either they were cynical or they
were
ignorant naive but when this when this
came out when the when the first reports
came out about this that
the police were using a military was
shooting at the i just knew it wasn't
true
i knew it wasn't true because of how
many times the the
media had lied about trump i knew it
wasn't true because that's just not the
sort of thing that happens
i knew it's not true because there would
have been actual political blowback
had one done this one wouldn't have
risked this sort of thing
if you perpetually fall for this fake
news or if you perpetually
put out this fake news you are not
worthy of being believed right your word
is not worth very much whether you're on
the left or whether you're on the
pretend right
you just that's it
so you can't keep falling for it you
can't do that lie after lie after lie
when people
ask michael how come how come some kooky
conspiratorial
conservatives have questions about
whatever the vaccine or have questions
about the way the election was conducted
or have questions about this or about
that
it's not the conservatives fault if we
recognize that the media and the
government
and the big tech companies and the
bureaucracy lie to us
all the time and they always lie in one
direction they always lie to defend
the dominant liberal regime and they
always lie to
suppress the any sort of conservative
movement
so it's not not our fault that they've
squandered their credibility it's their
fault
and it's why i'm just going to assume if
we are
told something certainly something about
conservatives certainly something that
will have
political ramifications on how we behave
i'm just going to assume it's not true
if it is coming certainly in the heat of
heat of
the political moment certainly from
these leftist outlets
and and from the the government
bureaucracy the deep state the blob
from that as well and yet
and yet some liberals leftists whatever
words you want to use
think that the democrats actually are
too lenient
on conservatives aoc
says quote during the obama
administration folks thought we'd have a
60 democrat majority for a while
it lasted four months democrats are
burning precious time
and impact negotiating with gop who
won't even vote for the january 6th
commission
mcconnell's that's the only way i can
pronounce that date by january the worst
day
the day which will live in infamy worse
than pearl harbor
when the horn guy stole the lectern
mcconnell's plan
is to run out the clock it's a hustle we
need to move
now we need to move now
also by the way just a point on this
because of course aoc
keeps coming back to january 6th part of
the reason
that i am making fun of the pearl
clutching over january 6th
part of the reason is not even because
of the events itself the events
themselves rather
but because i just don't believe the way
the media reported on it remember the
media reported so
the media has lied to us about every
single event that in any way could be
constructed as
right-wing violence or even
fictionalized as right-wing violence
when the left burns the country down for
eight months that's mostly peaceful when
the right does anything when the right
blows its nose that's right-wing
violence
but the story of january 6 has
completely unraveled
the story began that trump supporters
were killing cops remember
officer sicknick had a fire extinguisher
thrown at his head
and that killed him these murderers
these cop killers on the right
and this was reported by the new york
times and the washington post and it was
just completely made up
even these these news outlets had to
correct themselves on page 700
months and months later at when at which
point no one was paying attention
anymore
but it didn't happen officer sicknick
died of a stroke an
unrelated health problem days later
so yes i am going to make fun of the
january 6th commission because i just
don't believe it i don't believe the
propaganda that they're putting out
about it
because they have squandered their
credibility on the left
aoc is wrong about this though aoc i
think is usually pretty politically
savvy
i'm not saying she's got a whole lot
going on between the ears i'm not saying
she's
read a ton of history or philosophy or
anything like that but she
knows how to position herself to amass
more and more political power
but she's wrong about this political
point that she's making that
that the word democrats are wasting
precious time
because if they keep trying to negotiate
with republicans they're not going to
get what they want
the liberal establishment which includes
the democratic party and all the major
institutions
i think basically every single
institution including the military at
this point
the liberal establishment will get
whatever it wants
it is the dominant regime in this
country it is the way that
politics actually works i know that you
you learned in your civics class
actually you probably didn't because we
don't have civics classes anymore
but if if we did what you would have
learned in your civics class is
that we have three branches of
government and a separation of powers
and checks and balances
and the you know i am a bill and i call
myself bill and the
congress makes the laws and and then
they're signed by the president or
they're sent back and then this but
that's not actually how the government
works do you know who makes the laws
like the fda that's who makes the laws
the atf makes the laws
congress does not really make that many
laws
and when congress does make laws
congress is usually just giving
guidelines
to the administrative agencies who
actually make the laws you know who else
makes the laws
google google makes the laws because
yes we have free speech and certain
speech protections
but we can't really exercise that speech
because a handful of corporations
control the flow of information around
our public square
and those corporations will severely
curtail your right to free speech
in reality google has quite a lot to say
about your i mean mitch mcconnell said
this the other day he said woke
corporations
constitute a parallel government
this is true throughout the institutions
and
if democrats are not getting something
that they want right now
it is because the liberal establishment
the actual ruling power
just doesn't really want it and look
there's a republican party and there
are some conservatives and the only ones
who are
buoyed who are put on major television
all the time
who are put on network tv who are
allowed to have positions
and esteemed positions in the
institutions are the ones
who do not threaten that liberal
establishment they're the ones
who push back just enough
to make it seem like there's real
dissent and real debate in this country
but ultimately they lose ultimately they
roll over they lose with dignity
is what they say right i don't think
they're very dignified but they say they
lose with dignity
they're they are the court jesters in
the kingdom of liberalism
the establishment will get whatever it
wants and so aoc when aoc is picking a
fight over this it's not about
republicans and democrats
it's about an intra-democrat fight it's
about a fight within
the liberal establishment because that's
the only power that
actually matters in the country
the powers that be
will basically do whatever they want if
you don't
realize that after the year that we have
just had then i don't know how to
convince you
they upended the entire american way of
life
they curtailed many of your political
rights they shut down churches and
opened up marijuana dispensaries and
didn't even have to give you a reason
the scientists changed their minds on
very basic things
sometimes by the hour and they laugh at
you when you raise a question about that
dana carvey you know dana cory is one of
the great impressionists
ever basically and a really funny
comedian and he's he was on snl
dana carvey who at least in his public
life
seems to lean left you know he was
always very nice about
obama and his you know he's had a lot of
mainstream success
dana just did a bit on his podcast
mocking this very fact mocking the
arbitrariness of the power
of the established regime mocking
how little the the this establishment is
accountable to the people
and how little they care what the people
think he he mocked it in the person of
one tony fauci but if
it's proven the virus escaped from a lab
i'll have no regrets but if i have my
brothers i hope the whole world
forgets i'm
tony fauci
[Applause]
and from the bottom of my heart
[Music]
go
[Music]
go [ __ ] yourself we'll be right back
with kelsey grandma
so the whole the whole bit is that
tony fauci is this kind of like crooner
like
late night host so he's doing him kind
of as a sinatra
or a dean martin i will say you know
dana carvey has
some of the greatest impressions ever
the tony fauci
i don't know the voice is not quite i
think the character is there the voice i
don't know i don't know i'm just saying
some other people do impressions and you
know one can judge for oneself
the point he's making though is totally
right i'm tony fauci
and you can go f yourself that's what i
care about you you stupid peasants
i'm tony fauci he doesn't obviously he's
not accountable and he is just
he's a real person but he's a symbol of
that that broader
administrative state the public health
bureaucracy that just doesn't care you
can complain and we can talk until we're
blue in the face
but they've got the political power and
we don't that's the way it is speaking
of not caring
kamala harris was was asked sort of a
tough question on univision for goodness
sakes univision
a very leftist television station she
was asked a question about this
immigration issue
and she couldn't take the heat and she
snapped
i said i'm going to go to the border and
when are you going to the border
vice president administration has asked
i'm not finished
i've said i'm going to the border and
also if we are going to deal with the
problems at the border
we have to deal with the problems that
cause people to go to the border
to flee to the border and that is the
root causes
so my first trip as vice president of
the united states
was to go in terms of a foreign trip to
guatemala
to be on the ground there to address and
to
and to be informed of the root causes
why are the people of guatemala leaving
do you have a date
i i will keep you posted i will keep you
posted i love
good good on this reporter because
everyone's been asking hey kamala you
know you're on this guatemala trip
you're apparently in charge of
immigration now
because joe biden wanted to toss you
right under that bus you remember that
bus
that you said brought black students to
white schools that you said joe biden
opposed because joe biden's a terrible
racist and that do you remember that bus
well he's
throwing it right underneath it because
i think there is no love lost between
joe biden and kamala harris and he gave
her an impossible job
and she's failing at that impossible job
in a spectacular way so she goes to
guatemala
and she's asked this question when are
you going to the border
and her answer well i'll go eventually
and the reporter says yeah
give me a date i'm not finished i'm
that's
kamala's favorite line she thinks this
plays well i don't think this plays well
i think this plays well
with very angry single feminist women
and that's i guess the democratic base
it's a
big part of the democratic base but it's
not a huge constituency and to the rest
of us
this just seems so shrill
it seems unprofessional it seems
deceptive she obviously just doesn't
want to answer the question and then
this reporter doesn't back down good on
her and by the end
she goes give me the date kamala and
kamala goes well i'll keep you posted
she don't care it doesn't it just
doesn't matter this might be bad for her
political career
but for the broader power structures in
the country does it just doesn't really
matter
the trip was not a huge success
the way you know this is because it is
being reported in cnn that white house
staffers think it was a failure
now i just went on a long rant
about how i don't believe things that
are in cnn
but i want to make sure we're specific
here
there are different ways of covering
stories
okay when cnn a leftist outlet
covers a republican president like
donald trump
and quotes anonymous white house
staffers i i
generally don't believe it i'm not
saying it's never true but i gen
my dis my inclination is not to believe
it because i know that those two
organizations
are adversaries cnn is out to get trump
trump is out to get cnn
so i just don't buy it when cnn is
reporting
on the biden white house i'm much more
inclined to believe in
because cnn and the biden white house
are not adversaries they're partners
they're on the same team
and so when cnn is reporting something
from the biden white house
it is because biden wants to send a
message
and the message is being sent to kamala
the the white house staffers
believe that she looked ill prepared
according to this report
and uh and that her bad answers
overshadowed this sort of thing
there are it's really worth pointing out
when we're talking about
how to judge propaganda that comes out
of the government or out of
the big corporations or out of the the
media
they're all kind of part of the same
thing there simply are different
standards
of judging these places when they're
talking about democrats and when they're
talking about republicans
just like there's different standards
when we're talking about a blm terrorist
versus a
capital rioter there are different
standards when we're talking about
democrats or republicans here being
covered aoc has a more radical take
though
aoc has a radical take here on on this
immigration question
she says that the immigration crisis is
actually america's fault
what we as a country what the united
states
has not done is actually own up to the
fact
that we have contributed to regime
change
destabilization and interventionist
foreign policy
that has contributed to these awful
conditions
throughout latin america and the reason
that it's
a problem and this is not just u.s
supporting regime change
this is also climate policy that
is impacting the global south
disproportionately
even though these farmers and these
folks in central and south america
contributed to climate change the least
in terms of their carbon emissions
they are experiencing the ravages the
most
right now and first and so u.s climate
policy
has contributed to this u.s foreign
policy u.s economic and trade policy
has helped contribute to conditions um
that
that people are fleeing so the point
she's making that the u.s has intervened
in latin america that part's true
the idea that the us interventions have
made latin america worse that part's
false
she's basically saying if we hadn't
prevented communist revolutions in latin
america
the societies would be flourishing right
now and we just know that's not the case
and that's not how communism works no
matter what aoc wants
number three though the idea that
because we have
intervened with our neighbors like every
other country in the history of the
world
because we have international
relationships that somehow
now we have a responsibility to knock
down our borders and take in
the entire population of guatemala
that's preposterous that doesn't make
any sense
that is uh it's it's the way the left
argues is they'll
make one sort of true observation and
then a bunch of non-sequiturs
will will come from that and that will
lead them to this this radical idea
it's not just her though by the way joe
biden the whole administration is
radical i mean joe biden is now
in his budget is replacing the term
mothers with birthing people okay so
it's not it's the whole
kitten caboodle is moving radically
radically
to the left you know you can now find
all the conservative content that you
love wherever you are
on the daily wire app even if you're not
a daily wire subscriber you'll be the
first to know
what's trending with mobile
notifications so download the daily wire
app and stay up to speed
with the freshest conservative voices
around no matter where you are
on this show every day i talk about a
lot of amazing products and services
from sponsors that i use and love
but we want to get to know you better so
that we can choose our sponsors with you
in mind we've been running a survey for
a couple weeks now to get to know our
audience members better
if you haven't already taken it it is
not too late go to dailywire.com
knowles fill out my audience survey and
tell us
a little more about yourself to sweeten
the deal everyone who completes the
survey will be entered to win a 1 000
gift card you can only take the survey
once per daily wire show though so if
you want to increase your chances of
winning the thousand bucks
go listen to ben go listen to drug or
listen to matt to get access to all
their surveys as well
dailywear.com knowles we would love to
hear from you and we will be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week the mailbag
from brian hey michael i saw a billboard
the other day and it said smile your mom
chose life
since you're an experienced linguist
someone who knows a lot about linguistic
warfare is this a message that
pro-lifers
should push to me it's playing to the
left and insinuating that there is a
choice
i believe it should say something like
smile you didn't get murdered in the
womb
thank you sir uh it's a good question i
you know
i don't i don't necessarily mind
the billboards because they are they are
acknowledging that there is a choice i
mean just like
you have a choice to murder someone it's
in murder is illegal abortion is legal
murder
of a person who's not inside a womb is
illegal
and yet you still have a choice you can
choose to murder someone or not and if
you choose to you'll face consequences
so i i think as a
this is rare that you'll hear me say
this the language here is
not the biggest issue the biggest issue
is the law
if there were consequences for
performing abortions
you would have less abortion if there
were legal consequences uh
yes we got to be careful in our language
we should refer to unborn babies as
babies we shouldn't refer to whatever
stupid terms the left uses
we shouldn't refer to it as women's
healthcare or a choice or whatever
um but i actually think this slogan you
know smile your mom chose life
really drives home this idea that
the question is not just about the
political rights of totally abstract
persons and one's body and this it's
actually
the relationship between a mother and
her child and as mother teresa pointed
out saint teresa of calcutta now
she pointed this out in a speech to the
u.n abortion
is the driver of of so many evils in the
world it might be the single most evil
thing going on in the world
because if a mother can kill her child
there is nothing
that that anyone can't do so i kind of
like the billboard but
i think the the way that really we need
to make clear there isn't a choice is by
taking away that choice is by making it
illegal from marissa michael i've
recently started learning about the law
of attraction
and manifestation at first it discussed
how you can just ask the universe for
what you want
truly believe you have already received
it and it will manifest in your life
i wanted to find out if this was real
and connected to god with him
being the universe because it is hard to
trust if god is not the ultimate source
of manifesting
matthew 21 22 says and all things
whatsoever you shall ask in prayer
believing you shall receive
what are your thoughts on the validity
of the law of attraction and manifesting
things into your life warm regards if
you can dream it can you do it
my short answer is stop that right now
cut it out stop it
this is a very bad idea for those of you
who haven't heard of it the idea of the
law of attraction or manifestation
is part of the new age religion it's
become very popular of the last
few decades it's a form of occultism
it's a form
of it's also sort of a form of
gnosticism
and at a very basic level if to use
biblical terms
it's a form of magic and sorcery which
is roundly condemned in the bible
you've made one major a few theological
errors but one major one here is
you've said that god is the universe but
that's not true
god created the universe god is the
creator and we are in
creation right now but he is not the
universe the idea that god is the
universe
is uh called pantheism right the idea
that really it's all just out there and
the way that this new age religion works
is it creates an
idol and a false god out of your ability
to you know if you think it you can do
it you
see this in lots of popular books like
the secret and things like that um
but it's it's uh heretical because you
are suggesting that you have not only
the power to manipulate the universe
but you you have the power to control
god and obviously
that's you do not and that that is
incoherent
so i would uh i would really drop this
as soon as you can
it's uh you know there's nothing new
under the sun we talk about this often
with the transgender idea that actually
transgenderism
is just an actually another form of
gnosticism and for those who don't know
what gnosticism means
that that means uh that you
your understanding of religion and of
the universe relies upon
secret knowledge that this gnostic is
really the secret the secret knowledge
that you can possess and once you know
the secret knowledge then you can
basically make yourself into a god uh
but that that's not christianity all
right that's not that's not our religion
so the
gnosticism of transgenderism is that
you're a boy but you secretly know
you're a girl so actually you are a girl
and the gnosticism here is you're living
in certain circumstances but you
secretly know that you can force the
universe to come
into a line with the tyranny of your
will and
uh that that is not true
and uh if if any of it ever does work it
certainly ain't coming from god
so not to belabor the point but stop
practicing
sorcery please marissa
from nick hi michael me again oh this
looks like a related question what are
your thoughts on astrology
i'm currently living a single life so my
tinder inbox looks like someone's home
mailbox who went to mexico and never
came home
which is awesome however so many of
these babes are into astrology
and there is no filter yet to weed them
out my question is a is astrology real
and b
if so should it be a turn off because
it's well demonic correspondence and
influence over weak-minded women who
want to find themselves
thanks sincerely the not wanting to
shack up with fallen stars
i think you've answered your own
question nick but you do get the point
this is probably
one of my least popular opinions but it
happens to be correct
the problem with astrology my friend
josh herm at this point the other day on
twitter
the problem with astrology and the
reason that you should not consult
astrologers
is not that it is fake and silly and a
waste of your time
it's that it's real and it compromises
your free will so
so there is something to this now i'm
not saying that every
two-bit charlatan who's doing a palm
reading or something is actually telling
you your future
but i am saying that the idea of
astrology
is to
throw away one's entire free will and
try to get a leg up on
on reality and to try to make oneself
into a god in some ways and uh so i just
wouldn't do it yeah it's bad
now a lot of people they say oh you know
what's your sign are you a sagittarius
or whatever and you know
i suppose that's all innocent enough as
long as you sort of discourage it and
get that gal going to church all right
from jolene hey michael
i was recently at a wedding where i
caught up with one of the groomsmen
i had met several times over the years
anyway the guy had his girlfriend at the
wedding
but decided to tell me he had always
been interested in me he said he never
said anything
because he didn't want to mess things up
with his friend since i was like his
sister and never thought i was
interested
though i've always had a crush on him he
has now been reaching out on social
media with a very flirtatious
vibe i'm single but he is still in that
relationship and i respect that
but it doesn't seem like he really does
we don't live in the same city so
nothing will really happen but at what
point should i shut him down
should i tell him i'd be interested in
pursuing things if he were single or
just leave what could have been
in the past in all sincerest humility
dolly's inspiration of jolene jolene
i'm begging of you please don't take my
man
i'm gonna try to be nice to this guy
here
let's say he's not a cad let's say he's
not a total player let's say that
actually he's just doing this to you
which might well be the case he might
just actually have this secret longing
for you and this is this opportunity
that came up
um this is not the way to start a great
relationship this is not the way to
start something that will lead to
marriage
in an act of infidelity if this guy
really wants to pursue you
uh and it's not just his passions
running away with him and these sorts of
things happen
it happens to men and women but if it's
not just his passions running away with
you because
people had a few too many drinks at a
wedding and whatever
then he needs to just dump his
girlfriend and pursue you
and if he's if he's not going to do that
if he's trying to have his cake and eat
it too
i would i would ignore it it's not not
good for him not good for you not a good
way to start things
jolene jolene from john dear michael i'm
a high school teacher
from behind the wire in california we
just went through our first critical
race theory staff development
and now there will be a new course here
in california called ethnic studies they
added that
at college when i was there they added
that as a major this was now 10 years
ago but it's now it's obviously coming
throughout all these schools and
workplaces john goes on it is assumed
the curriculum will be a far leftist's
dream come true i currently teach
advanced us history but some have been
encouraging me to jump up to the front
to teach this new class in order to
bring the course back to some level of
reality
and save the kids from commie propaganda
what do you think should i jump in and
save the kids
p.s i pre-ordered your book speechless
controlling words controlling minds i
can't wait to get it oh thank you
yes that book you know that book is
coming out in 11 days in 11 days i will
no longer be able to say
that i have this new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order it will just
be available
for order so
the question is how much control you
will have over the classroom
i i believe that
if you can infiltrate this class and
make it
good make it a good class sneak in a
conservative worldview and take away the
leftist view that's intrinsic to this
this field of study quote unquote
then that would be great that's what the
left did right the left infiltrated
all the traditional institutions and
took them over
and turned them to their ends so i think
we need to do the exact same and one
good way to do that
would be for you to teach this class
however if the class has this set
curriculum
that insists on things like whatever
whiteness must be abolished you know
the story that we started with today
from that medical journal if it insists
on things like
systemic racism and it's not referring
to affirmative action
then it might not be worth your time
because you might just be spinning your
wheels it depends how much freedom you
have in the classroom if you've got the
freedom
to turn this wicked stupid class into
something good
then absolutely do it and if you don't
run for the hills from golda
dear michael i'm in the summer before my
third year of law school
hoping to graduate in december i say
this to give you context i've already
sunk thousands of my own dollars
and taken out student loans to get to
this point my school is requiring
everyone to get the coveted vaccine
unless you can prove a religious or
medical exemption
i don't think i would qualify for either
i would personally like to wait until
there is more information to make that
decision about what to put in my body
decides if the school is going to
require masks and social distancing even
for vaccinated people
and everyone who would like to get the
vaccine can get it it should not matter
if i get the vaccine or not what should
i do
how hard should i push i'm frustrated
that i feel really alone in this i would
appreciate your advice i think you're
perfectly
within your rights and within reason to
say that the
medical establishment and the and the
propaganda wing of that establishment
that has lied to us for
over a year now should not be
necessarily trusted
and if you're a young healthy person
then you're really not at
great risk from this virus and when
people say well
there are no long-term effects from this
vaccine that's not possible to know
because the vaccine has existed for
about six months so
i get with seven or eight months at this
point so it's just there are no
long-term studies on it
um so i think you're totally right for
that you'll have to make a prudential
calculation
if you can get an exemption i would do
that i would pursue basically
every just and moral route to do that
and and i would i would try to do that
if you have to get the vaccine look i'm
not saying that i'll never get the
vaccine right i'm just saying it's a
risk calculation
so if one has to make the prudential
choice to get it because of other
considerations then you know
that's the way this world works but but
i think that
exploring every option you have to avoid
it i think is perfectly
right and smart and just from stephen
dear michael i'm a proud ginger-haired
man of sicilian descent
who just graduated college but i
suffered a traumatic episode caused by
past comments about my hair color and
minority status
i had finally accepted the under
representation of my people and realized
glm a ginger lives matter would never
take off
but then your colleague matt walsh
mentioned redheads cannot be trusted
i thought i was done with the days of
being called a day walker and a no soul
but no what are your thoughts on his
blatant heroism
and will the world ever recognize our
plight
thank you for your support sincerely the
ginger italian stallion first of all
i know you're saying you're italian here
but you might
you might want to check with the mailman
i don't know i i haven't seen a lot i
guess there was barbarossa right
barbarossa is a red-haired italian
but but i'll take i'll take you at your
word on your ethnicity
this is very difficult you are very
oppressed um the good news for you is
you're not going to worry about this for
for very long
because the medical establishment wants
to find a permanent cure
to your skin color so i don't it's just
not gonna it's gonna be a moot point i
think if they
if they get their way last question from
adam mr knowles i've been having trouble
with my confidence in showing who i am
politically my parents are squish
republicans and anytime i speak out
about my beliefs i'm shut down
by words recycled through leftist media
i love my parents a lot but it gets
constricting getting belittled and
disrespected all the time
when i feel like i don't have a voice
when politics comes up in conversation
do you have any suggestions or tips on
helping with political confidence and
making your voice heard
when you need to take a stance on what
you believe in yes here's my advice read
a lot
know much more consider all of their
views and figure out why they're wrong
or if they're right and adopt those
views but
i guess more likely than not they're
going to be wrong and know that you are
correct
and then you don't need to boast and
yell and scream and brag about it
because when people know that they're
correct they can be very calm they can
be cool as a cucumber the ones who
scream and yell their head off all the
time are the ones
who who do not feel very confident in
their views so there's a very catholic
view i guess the idea that just suffer
suffering is
quite sanctifying actually when they're
talking about how great
i don't know obama is or something the
new how terrible trump is and just you
just know that you are correct
calmly say your point
because i find that sort of calmness and
just knowing the facts and getting it
out there
cuts through all the noise that's our
show i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show
we'll see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin